hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
i'm kathleen sebelius is hair stylist
Dave Rubin and I've got Cara Santa Maria
and Dylan Brodie with me and let's get
right to it
Obamacare the train wreck continues I've
been for this thing I believe that
everyone can and should have health care
but the website not working well and
even the libs are turning on it and they
say when you've lost Jon Stewart you've
lost the country and it looks like Obama
may have lost Jon Stewart maybe a bit
concerning that the president was not
kept in the loop about the program that
is named after him but in his defense
there appeared to be very few loops for
the first time the government reveals
that it monitored some 35 world leaders
including German Chancellor Angela
Merkel perhaps more shocking is that
President Obama was kept in the dark
about it for five years so for five
years
I assume the president is being
presented with the findings from this
world leader monitoring and in those
five years that never occurred to him to
say how we getting this does the
president believe in surveillance
fairies all right so he didn't know
about this NSA thing you know whether
you think Benghazi is a scam blur or not
he didn't really know about that or the
IRS but what's really getting him is all
the quotes that they have of him talking
about Obama can't remember if you like
your plan you can keep it period
you can keep your plan if you are
satisfied with it if you like the plan
you have you can keep it if you like
your plan and you like your doctor you
won't have to do a thing you keep your
place if you like your health care plan
you will be able to keep your health
care plan if you've got health insurance
you can keep it if you like your health
care plan you will keep your plan if
you've got health insurance do you like
your doctor you like your plan you can
keep your doctor you can keep your plan
if you have insurance that you like then
you will be able to keep that insurance
if you like your doctor or health care
plan you can keep it if you like your
health care plan you can keep your
health care plan
alright so New York Magazine put that
compilation together and it actually
goes further than that but
this is YouTube so we got time
constraints okay so let's start with
this first off just from watching that
little clip right there before we get to
the Jon Stewart stuff do you think
politicians all hate YouTube and hate
the Internet because we can now track
the lies you know even 10 years ago you
couldn't track the lies I think somebody
reporters were still tracking the lives
but but everyone can get it at a quick
now any troll can do it right but I
definitely think that this is something
that would have been caught regardless
and I guess the big question is is this
actually a lie or is this something
where he was trying to sell the the
country an idea that in his mind was
fully formed that he then had to pass in
the Congress in order to you know
implement it and so he was selling an
idea that was one idea and then as we
all knew the law was changed piecemeal
by piecemeal in order to get it to pass
right so do you think he possibly didn't
know that he was gonna end up lying
because everyone's saying they changed
so much the whole story is amiss Lee
because the there's a cherry-picking of
anecdotal evidence that shows some
people have had to give up plans Reyes
that's a tiny percentage 5% of the
people who are previously insured we're
now having to give up their insurance
and those five are having to give up
their insurance because their insurance
was inadequate
it just doesn't meet the requirements of
the mandate and many of those will be up
for help governmental help for for
paying for the new insurance right
supposedly they'll get better insurance
you know that's not what it said it
seems I'm arguing that they will get
better insurance yes but their premiums
are gonna go up there's a subsidy that
can come in to help cover that that
premium going up so what we're really
dealing with is not a question whether
he lied but whether he underestimated
how low people would go in their
insurance before they were dissatisfied
with it he was thinking well clearly
people who have really crappy insurance
don't like their insurance right if you
have insurance you like you're going to
be able to keep anyone know I really
liked
crappy insurance right which he just
didn't anticipate but what is he
thinking that or was he doing what
you're saying which I tend to think is
probably a little closer to truth which
is he just had to sell it so he had to
keep repeating that because he had to
sell it and then once it's through then
all the nuance of the little details
that you're describing come to light but
he had to sell it so he had to keep
saying I mean it's one thing to call
somebody out on a lie about something
that hasn't happened yet you know that's
a failed promise more than it is I think
a bold-faced lie it's one thing to lie
and you know who knows what's going on
with the NSA tapes right with all of
this evidence we don't know what Obama
was privy to and what he wasn't and we
don't know how much of that truth he's
actually hiding but I think preemptively
to say in the future things will be this
way is that really lying right it's
really just an over promise and I don't
I don't I still think it's not even an
over promise he just didn't realize that
there were people who went no I like
crappy insurance yeah and that you know
that wouldn't occur to me okay so let's
get to what we started with which is the
Jon Stewart stuff because I do think
it's interesting that Jon who really
basically is the most trusted man in
media is sort of turning against Obama
and it has more to do with the NSA stuff
I think and I've been talking about this
for weeks on here it seems to me that
they purposely don't tell Obama things
that they don't tell him that the
website for Obama care wasn't quite
gonna work it's now come out he didn't
know and he didn't know that the NSA was
spying like their purpose tactic I think
in large corporations where the CEO
ultimately you know holds the
responsibility for decisions that are
made so you know the board may make a
decision or people underneath it may
make a decision and intentionally not
not disclose at him so that he can't
then later be held responsible is that a
decent way for government ivory was
pioneered by the darling of the right
Ronald Reagan it is under his
administration that we were introduced
to the expression plausible deniability
right and it's have that written right
here
thing and I think it's very dangerous
it's you know the buck stops here so
please don't show me the buck if it
comes near me I have to stop it so
please keep the buck in the waiting room
I would like an antechamber full of bugs
that deniability really plausible yes
you exactly you see the results from the
wiretap how do you not know that they
came from a wiretap right and and also
you know it's funny you bring up the
plausible deniability cuz I do have a
written here but I have it written not
because of Reagan and I'm glad you
brought that if I ever in because of the
movie Independence Day because remember
when Bill Pullman the president finds
out about the aliens and he says well
why didn't I know about this and they go
plausible deniability so I get what
that's where I get my information from
yours I probably understand I well you
know Ronald Reagan really took plausible
deniability to a whole new Lanka during
his second term as president he didn't
know he was president the level of
plausible deniability there is really
extraordinary yeah okay so if this if
the system is built so that they
purposely don't tell him things and then
that way he's not quite lying then who's
really in charge here like is this
Illuminati stuff what are we really
talking about NSA really in charge and
and or is the FBI
like well I mean ultimately in the grand
scheme of things we know the big money
this is a real in church but but
fundamentally I mean there there's a
reason that we have a division of power
in this country right there's a reason
that we have the three different
branches of government so that they can
impose checks and balances on one
another the hope is that the executor
isn't ultimately in charge because that
would be too much power for one leader
in a democracy but at the same time when
it comes to the NSA scenario I think
that things are getting really really
out of hand we even saw that Dianne
Feinstein now is saying that like she
disapproves of wiretapping of all of our
allies in diplomatic arenas well she's
right many I mean she was one of the
people who ordered these things yeah
okay so let's wrap up with this then
because I think it's a great point this
idea that every time something gets
leaked by Snowden everyone pretends
they're outraged except we all feel like
we knew that this stuff was going on so
how does an AI an Feinstein sit there in
front of the committee
and pretend she either pretends she
doesn't know her now we're not gonna do
it anymore you've been doing that yeah
we have never done such a thing we will
never do such a thing and we've stopped
we won't ever again but fundamentally I
think the issue is that this is a it's a
political move it's not a move about
keeping Americans safe as long as we
knew that our own phones could be
wiretapping nobody seemed to have a
problem with it on the NSA until her on
the Intelligence Committee in Congress
but as soon as there were there
diplomacy was at stake right as soon as
this was detrimental to any sort of
political agenda
all of a sudden this is something that
we shouldn't be doing but all right we
do aren't we doing it to our allies and
our allies doing it to us like this is
this just standard spy verse pie like
psych 101 I think I think that's true
but I also think that we have
capabilities that are far beyond a fair
amount of other nations and so in some
time in some ways we have the upper hand
there I think we like to keep sense that
we are far more technologically advanced
than we are just for the sake of keeping
the populace intimidated a little bit
and I think there is a lot of of stuff
going on between the NSA the CIA the FBI
and of course b613 that where secrets
are being kept from each other for the
sake of proprietary information
gathering and data sourcing that is so
dangerous and so ugly and so nefarious
that to some degree at least even the
Intelligence Committee is shocked every
time they realize that they're not they
are not being told everything because we
have three branches of government and
then a whole bunch of super secret
organizations and I think it's ugly and
I and I think we should all stop
pretending that what we live in is a
land of freedom and
and free expression you just gave me the
perfect out for a segment so there you
go alright let's talk about the Tea
Party those crazy Kooks according to a
new Rasmussen poll I cannot believe this
42% of the people in America believe in
the Tea Party's basic ideals and then
another 42% believe in President Obama's
basic ideals that's nuts
those are complete polar opposites and
basically half the country believes one
thing half the country believes in the
other might have something to do with
our left brain right brain thing but
let's look at some some further numbers
57% of GOP voters have a favorable
opinion of the Tea Party movement 77% of
Democrats and 47% of voters not
affiliated with either major party view
the movement unfavorably and 47% of
voters believe neither party represents
the American people all right so these
numbers are really interesting and
there's there's a lot to go on here but
let's just start with this 4242 thing
because that seems completely nuts to me
that we could buy that well i everyone
talks about how polarized we are and of
course if you watch MSNBC you get one
set of views and if you watch Fox again
another presidential election it's like
literally neck-and-neck it's very rarely
you know it's always like 49 percent 449
person but doesn't this seem a little
more extreme because the Tea Party is
more to the right obviously than
mainstream Republicans and most people
would argue that Obama's probably a
little more to the left
I would argue that Obama is more to the
right of mainstream Libs of a more
centrist so what I'm seeing is actually
just a big push to the right across the
board and that's what worries me more
yeah the issue with the tea party thing
and I'm gonna sound like a horrible
educational elitist here oh and they
like that around here that is because I
personally feel that knowing things is
good the part of the difficulty with the
tea party numbers is that it's largely
made up of the undereducated
and if you've ever been a costed on
Venice Boulevard Venice Beach by the the
people who take surveys for the
Libertarian Party right what happens is
they start off with things that make
bourbon do you believe in freedom why
yes I do do you think that individual
responsibility is a good idea
yes I do and then you get like a third
of the way into the thing and then you
won't I can't agree with that do you
believe that the poor should be left to
starve in the street no and as with the
healthcare initiative if people hear
Obamacare they say no no no and then you
break it down into the individual
elements think of well yes I like that
one well yes I like that you can stay on
your parents until you're 26 right yes I
like that you can get health care it's
the same thing that goes on with Tea
Party supporters you say do you agree
that the the Tea Party has some good
ideas yes I do do you agree that there
should be more accountability yes I do
and then they say okay 42% say Tea Party
goes oh is that really an issue with I
mean III think I have to kind of say
that I probably disagree with the
premise that the majority of Tea Party
supporters are undereducated I think
that that's like a sweeping
generalization after the ones in Texas
I'm from Texas I know many tea I myself
am obviously a progressive voter I don't
I don't affiliate myself with either
party but I'm a progressive voter and I
have no interest in the Tea Party but
but I do I have to say I disagree with
that sweeping generalization I think the
issue here is more about polling polling
as as a as a function to try and show a
long time since I've had a good polling
polling argument I mean I think it's a
thousand people it's a thousand
representative voters and then they ask
questions in a way that there's only one
or it's either this answer or that
answer or I'm not sure yeah that's
always the case so do you fundamentally
believe in the tenets of the Tea Party
yes or no I mean what does that mean how
inclusive is that you know just to your
point that you were just making yeah and
isn't there something a little
intellectually dishonest about sort of
what the Tea Party's doing which is they
want the government to be incredibly
small right barely exist and yet when it
comes to things like women's rights and
gay rights and stuff like that they
still want to control you so they don't
like the big thing but they want it so
the Tea Party is fundamentally dishonest
from the start because it pretends to be
a grassroots organization
that is strongly empower Felisa ported
by big-money interests in the forms of
the Koch brothers and I believe Roger
Ailes and other unidentified individuals
with the pockets right so that there's
really a sense that that you can fool
51% of the people most of the time and
that'll be just fine
I think they pull on they pull from from
two different areas right they try to
build a grassroots movement of kind of
salt-of-the-earth individuals who are
interested in more I'd say libertarian
values and then they combine that with
this kind of Christian Right movement
and they can flate those two things and
that's where you see this this kind of
juxtaposition of we want to keep the
government out of our bedrooms but at
the same time we only want good
Christian values in our bedroom right
it's so bizarre because if they went on
the libertarian stuff I would support
that I'm a firm believer in low taxes
and and having the government be
basically out of our lives but it's the
other part we're going to get to a story
on that so my last thing on this is the
the last number we looked at there was
the 47% believe neither party represents
them I'm gonna guess that you guys sort
of agree with that as a general I think
forty seven percent and forty two
percent right that's another problem
with polling is that if you ask the
question a certain way you're going to
get a certain response right so forty
two percent like the Tea Party but then
47 percent don't like Obama and somehow
what do you think about that that's
basically half of the country's or is
saying well we don't like any of these
guys well I first of all we have to deal
with the myth of democracy as we run it
because I will point out we don't choose
who our candidates are we are given a
set of four or five people anointed by
the party to choose from and then we
were going to throw this Mentalist trick
you guys choose between the ace of
spades and the ace of clubs you guys
choose between the ace of diamonds
millions of hearts and then you choose a
diamond or a club and then you go and
complain about the suits for a couple of
years yeah so we're already dealing with
a closed-circuit of representation and
we are not being represented because
money is what drives the whole system
and more and more money is being taken
out of the hands of the middle class a
shrinking middle class and put into the
hands of the very wealthy and the very
wealthiest who's being represented so
more than forty foot seven percent of
the population isn't being represented
regardless of how few it is that have
figured that out thus far and that's the
thing I mean it's it's really maybe that
47% are the individuals who have gotten
wise to the idea that oh I think I'm
tired of voting against my own interests
yeah well they're finally getting wise
to it perhaps all right well one of the
guys who's playing for the 47% who don't
seem to like the government at all is is
Rand Paul and he gave a speech at
Liberty University this is Jerry Falwell
--zz college I suppose and he gave a
speech on eugenics now first off
apparently he stole a lot of the speech
from the movie Gattaca on Wikipedia he
like lifted it I don't know I don't want
to get into that I want to talk about
eugenics specifically all right so let's
let's take a look at what Rand Paul said
in your lifetime much of your potential
or lack thereof can be known simply by
swabbing the inside of your cheek are we
prepared to select out the imperfect
among us now eugenics and kara I'm gonna
let you give a slightly more scientific
explanation than I am
eugenics basically is the system by
which people can sort of select out the
less desirable sort of so if let's say
to obese people were mating and we
didn't want to have obese people mate
you would stop them from mating to get
rid of obesity which sort of maybe
sounds good but really is a very
slippery slope clean that up okay I'm
not by any means a eugenics expert but
but you know my background is in biology
and psychology and I think you do genex
as a concept is something that can be
approached historically sociological II
biologically whatever so I think
obviously a popular example is when we
look back to to Hitler's Germany right
and so we think about the idea of Hitler
wanted to have a pure race and so he
wanted to eliminate certain
people from from the population that he
felt dirtied up the race and I think
that this is the most extreme and most
disgusting example of eugenics and I
think that that's kind of what that name
makes people think about when they hear
that right and I think it's an easy
stick scare tactic right right for Rand
Paul to use and he wanted to so Hitler
wanted to do it to breed blond-haired
blue-eyed people basically and he wanted
to do it through breeding but also but
technology has changed now we're now it
can be done through science and they can
you know change your eye color this is
all still breeding so so basically what
he's trying to say is that if we can use
any sort of kind of genetic test to
figure out if somebody has an illness in
utero that's going to prevent them from
leading a full and healthy life for
example that it's it's immoral to
terminate that pregnancy and I think a
lot of people would disagree with that I
think a lot of people you know a woman
finds out that she's carrying a child
with a trisomy you know with Down
syndrome with some sort of issue that
would cause that child to live a life in
horrible pain or with some sort of issue
that would cause that child to you know
to not be able to live at all to not
survive the birthing process or much
after the birthing process many people
would say that's completely a valid
reason to terminate the pregnancy so I
think that he's taking you know he's
making a huge slippery slope argument
and and he's making a very extreme in
order to rally the true for Cuccinelli
like to be able to support Cuccinelli
there in Virginia right and again he's
doing this at Liberty University which
obviously is a Christian college so he's
playing to the religious base I get all
that and again it's that that
intellectual dishonesty and and self
confliction that goes not confliction
yeah because he's a big guy Rand yeah
follower and this is the very sort of
program that she would have been all for
Oh completely that's totally valid in
her mind and you know Mike can you just
explain for people that don't get why
that why she would be more that I read
was in favor of a full meritocracy that
whatever works is good and whoever has
the money deserves the money and whoever
is succeeding is and it's sort of a
social Darwinism never mind the fact
that by the end of her life she was
broke and living off of government
assistance because once she needed it it
was just fine I know I feel that I'm
Randa as a writer and as a philosopher
came up with very simple very clear
answers to questions that by all rights
should trouble us deeply throughout our
lives the last thing we should find for
them is simple clear answers and when
Rand Paul then says eugenics is this
horrible thing and a Christian
University be aware that in many ways
the Catholic Church itself has been
running the longest-running eugenics
project in history starting in the dark
age well before the dark ages when they
started pulling the most intellectually
capable members of society out making
them celibate bringing them into the
church and educating them while
encouraging those who weren't worthy of
that education to reproduce laughs bunny
rabbits thereby creating a you know
generation after generation after
generation of less capable critical
thinkers over now what centuries
unfortunately that strategy doesn't work
because as we all know evolution occurs
in a more Darwinian fashion it doesn't
occur no Lamarckian fashion right and
you can't pass on intelligence genes
it's just there's no evidence to support
the fact that intelligent people are
going to systematically breed more
intelligent offering just because of
their genetic makeup
I mean oftentimes if you're raised by
bright parents who who you know want to
foster intellectual curiosity and you
you're more likely to to become an
intellectual individual as it stands but
there's there's really no evidence to
support the fact that when smart people
breed they make smart babies and when
dumb people bring it they make dumb base
is there really no evidence of that
because I mean it totally shakes the
foundation of myself do you need a
minute you need a minute
a complicated issue to approach
biologically and psychologically but
fundamentally I think the point that
you're making that Rand Paul based on
his own kind of personal philosophy
right seems like he would be a huge
supporter of us this is again a
political move there has nothing to do
with what he actually thinks yeah it has
everything to do with trying to
manipulate a group of people that have
strong religious values into voting a
certain way okay I totally agree this is
against his political ethos and yet he's
doing it obviously and this goes to what
we were talking about a second ago about
the Tea Party and the religion whatever
you have to say to get the votes yes
also it within his philosophic so all
right so removing the religious part of
this for a sec Liberty can we're kind of
let's see if we can do it here just for
a second if we have the religious part
for a second isn't this eugenics
actually good but isn't this the next
step in human evolution that we will
systematically remove the things that
are bad about us that are genetically
wrong with us
and that we will it's as deep it's a
deep moral issue that I think regardless
of whether or not you you subscribe to
any sort of religious denomination can
still be a difficult one to swallow and
I think it's because it's a very nuanced
situation we already are not we're more
subject to what we would call artificial
selection right a natural selection
right we make decisions based on who
we're gonna make that are outside of
kind of random natural decisions right
so we're all doing it on a day to day
basis that we breed our dogs in order to
have very specific traits that was told
I'm not allowed to breed with my dog but
when you breed two dogs together what
you end up is a bunch of different
breeds of dog who looks so different
from a chihuahua to a Great Dane and
they're all the same species right and
you see that in some respects within
human kind right you see mating based on
all sorts of different reasons may be
based on looks may be based on
intelligence based on you know kind
whatever the case may be so we already
make decisions about how we're going to
procreate and where we're fundamentally
in charge of those decisions so on the
light end you might want to call that
eugenics I don't know on the heavy end
trying to wipe out certain people
because we disagree with them
philosophically because we disagree with
them politically I think I'm an atheist
I don't I don't subscribe to a religion
at all and I'm very much against
organized religion but that to me is
fundamentally immoral right because you
could you could eliminate if they found
the gay gene this is what everyone says
they'll find the gay gene and then
they'll get rid of gays just another
reason to to kind of have an in-group
out-group status and to to push a hate
agenda so I think you've got to find
that middle ground where we're talking
about somebody who's not a person yet
right you're talking about an embryo and
that embryo has such heavily such heavy
genetic damage that it's going to create
a life that potentially couldn't live on
its own or that would be in such pain
and would struggle so much that the
mother because it is still her person
right as long as that is still an embryo
inside of her it's a it's a human rights
issue and she has the right to terminate
that pregnancy I think that's a
completely different issue than you Jeff
yeah you just wrote out so much good
stuff we're going to do another segment
but first of all for the record let me
also say that that I am also an atheist
I am so completely an atheist that when
people tell me they believe in God I
don't believe them it makes no sense to
me yeah I think we get into trouble when
we talk about is this good or bad
that we can do it because I think
science at its in in its purest form is
neither good nor bad it is neutral the
question is how new discoveries and new
abilities are then applied and you draw
the line at what a life be in so much
pain or so incapable of taking care of
itself my mind would be will it be
forced to live with my parents but there
you know there are all sorts of
different lines that can be drawn and
these are very individual decisions and
very individual choices and they lie
with the woman in question they lied to
some degree with the man in question if
there's a nuke
mr. who's gonna wind up raising this was
a voting public I mean fundamentally
what what you're saying about about
science I do think that there is some
morality wrapped up in the science
because science fundamentally is done by
people and they have agendas before they
set out to do their science but
ultimately I think that regulation is to
be left to the regulators and I think
that a voting public needs to be
choosing how we regulate and it that's
what you need true democracy where the
voting public is making the decision not
moneyed interests that are then chosen
by the voting public to represent the
supposedly voting public's interest and
in fact is right and we and we keep our
voting public so dumb that they're not
informed well enough to make the right
decisions on this kind of stuff but all
right we got a perfect segue here
because I was driving down La Cienega
here in LA yesterday and I saw this
billboard and I tweeted it out because I
could not believe it let's take a look
okay who's in the middle of LA like the
heart of LA to all our atheist friends
thank God you are wrong Answers in
Genesis dot org
now I tweeted it out and I tagged you
and you retweeted it and then a zillion
people retweeted it and then I started
doing a little more research on it turns
out this is not just in LA this thing
there is a massive digital billboard for
it in Times Square right now
okay there's obviously no audio there
because it's digital billboard in the
middle of Times Square so the guy who
created this thing is Ken Ham and you
may know Ken Ham because he is the guy
that started the Creation Museum in
Kentucky
what's the Creation Museum well we've
got a picture from there - yeah that's
what appears to be a caveman or a cave
boy and he's playing with a dinosaur
enjoying the smell from bee yeah this is
the dinosaur fart exhibit is what you're
looking at there okay so we got a lot
here to work with now just first off
let's just look at the billboard for a
second it actually struck me as
offensive it's really hard to offend me
I'm a comedian I believe in free speech
the guy can do whatever he wants but I
just kept thinking as I was watching
that if you had said hey Jews hey
Muslims thank God you are wrong people
would be up in arms but it seems to me
you're still allowed to attack atheist I
think that I think fundamentally and I
could be wrong about this but that
billboard was a direct response to an
atheist movement billboard that was all
also posted I can't remember what the
atheist movement billboard said but it
was something about being inclusive and
you know atheism is not powerful and
then this response came up that was I
think tongue-in-cheek
I mean it's obviously tongue-in-cheek
but it's it's like it's sharp and biting
but also kind of kind of like all of my
you know Christian friends in Texas
they're so kind exactly and so uh but I
don't know I mean it doesn't offend me
maybe it's because I'm just so cynical
about it at this point and I've
developed such a thick skin but yeah I
mean thank you so really having her free
speech right okay so I'm not saying that
you can't do it I'm really I'm not he
can you can do whatever you want say
whatever you want but really had it been
oh hey Jews hey Muslims
thank god you're wrong I I you know what
do people be going by the twinge of that
every time I see any religious
advertisement and any but to my mind
it simply proves how misguided organized
religion is to begin with yeah because
if you believe if you genuinely believe
there is an all-knowing all-powerful
deity that created the world and is so
ego-driven than it needs everybody to
speak its name in the right way in order
for it to grant them whatever they think
they're going to be granted does it
really need a marketing department and
that's I mean I seems very insecure
individually that's a very good point I
think what this Vil board really goes to
show is how incredibly threatened Ken
Ham feels okay by this new kind of
organized we're starting to see more
organization within the atheist movement
and so when you have organizations like
American atheist or like the Richard
Dawkins foundation the Freedom From
Religion Foundation whatever and they
actually are doing kind of billboards of
their own or they're starting to get
people together to get out the message
and all the sudden Ken Ham says oh [ __ ]
yeah you know are people gonna buy into
this I got to do something about it
that shows that he he thinks that this
is a legitimate movement and he thinks
that that it's got power yeah so are
atheists actually coming out of the
closet now so to speak please we last
time you were on the show we did a thing
about how Barney Frank who was openly
gay in Congress for 25 years he had to
wait or seemingly had to wait until he
retired to finally announce that he was
an atheist so is there an actual
movement and do they see it as a threat
I I think it's starting to happen I
think the Internet in many ways has
freed up people to express their true
selves in ways that they couldn't before
people with odd fetishes people with
outside of the mainstream religious
beliefs or lack of religious beliefs
people who have had thoughts that that
made them feel entirely isolated and
alone in a world that presented religion
particularly our nation presented
religion as the norm and and a very
particular puritanical kind of religion
as the norm found out that they were not
alone in the world and they immediately
begin communicating and and wanting to
organize and get together and tweet up
as to work yeah we got past worries but
I think one of the fundamental issues
with with
a conversation about there being an
atheist movement is that at its core
atheism is a lack of belief in a higher
power so I always try to make the
distinction when I talk to people about
my own atheism that it's not that I
believe there is no God it's that I
simply don't believe in a God and when
you have a lot of different people who
simply don't believe that there's a
higher power that exists there's nothing
fundamental banding them together
there's no there's no tenets of atheism
there's no mantra there's no church that
we go to and so because of that talking
about an atheist movement I think makes
more sense in in when we reference maybe
a secular movement a group of
individuals who understand that we want
to protect the First Amendment that we
want to keep church and state separate
that we want to make sure that religious
interests aren't aren't impeding on our
own rights as individuals and fringing
on our own rights and that you know a
secular nation from a governing
perspective is a nation that we need to
uphold it's not really about getting an
atheist agenda so here's how difficult
it is for us to my dealer I actually
disagree oh the other way on it I don't
it's not that I don't believe in a god I
believe there is no God I believe that
all of that is goofy superstitious
mythology and that that people do
believe it is baffling to me and part of
the difficulty we have is that the you
know the democracy as we practice it
comes and and more importantly
capitalism as we practice it comes out
of a feudal society and the feudal
society that comes out of was a
religious feudal society where the the
leaders were anointed by God and we have
not fully evolved beyond that as a
nation we still require our certainly on
the right we require they require the
their candidates to say God told me to
run and on the Left they require their
candidates to still say I believe in God
say I get
get Bible verses on my blackberry every
morning exactly there's this sort of nod
toward religion in the the fundamental
actions of our democracy as it stands
right now our political process yeah and
I think that we do have to be active as
atheists and as a secular community to
make certain that we continue to move
farther and farther away from feudalism
not back toward it okay so so final
thought on this hat then how do you if
you have two atheist here who sort of
believe in a slightly different version
of what that means to you personally how
do you gin up the base then because if
everything because it's so easy to do
for the religious people right and it's
so easy to do for the die-hard partisan
hacks on both sides how do you gin up a
base of rational they're very secular
people they're atheist who don't think
we should
there are many atheists who think that
this is not a movement and this is not a
group of people that should be banded
together there are other aces who do
think that there should I just I just
spoke last weekend at the CFI conference
or the CFI summit in to get a good game
okay I spoke earlier this year at
American atheist and there you know
humanist societies freethinker Society
skeptic societies where I often visit
and it takes all kinds and so I think
fundamentally again if you want to rally
a base and you want to have an organized
movement that movement needs to be a
political movement it's not gonna be a
religious movement because there's a
lack of religion here that's fundamental
to being an atheist yeah Dylan bring
this thing home I think if you want to
to support the idea of secular society
in a secular nation the way to do it is
by supporting the sciences by supporting
education by supporting anything that
promote the arts supporting anything
that promotes free thinking and critical
thinking and the expansion of the
intellect and the mind you've read at
home all right well guess what people
maybe we don't need God nor anything to
believe in because we have Facebook
that's right Facebook has now a
researchers at Cornell University have
figured out that Facebook can actually
predict whether you and your partner
will break up there's something called
the dispersion theory let's look at it
this is the Facebook theory of
dispersion as
written by the Cornell researchers they
took the datasets of 1.3 million
Facebook users listed as being in a
relationship and found that the more
well-connected their mutual friends were
the more likely they were to break up
now I thought this was kind of
interesting because it and I would have
thought if you have a lot of mutual
friends it means you have a lot of
mutual interests and a lot of
connections maybe a family whatever and
that that would give you more reason to
stay together but this actually proved
the rivers I think if you have a lot of
mutual friends you're that much more
likely to wind up out at dinner one
night going wait you told him I like
this I think much as we need separation
of church and state there is some need
for a separation of family and social
life and you know that's some overlap of
course there's some overlap but you know
sometimes I like to just go out and
spend time with people who have a
separate existence with a separate set
of interests and then when I'm done I go
home and untie my wife all right well
let's take a couple look at some of the
other findings here so couples with high
dispersion have mutual friends who are
not well connected and couples with low
dispersion have mutual friends who are
well connected now what I think is
interesting about this and I think
you'll buy into this is that this isn't
totally a scientific survey because the
subset of people that you're talking
about here are all people that are on
Facebook which may be only a certain
type of person is on Facebook who have
chosen yes play that they're in a
relationship which is I think another
subset right I've never once said
whether or not I'm in a relationship on
Facebook we need to ask you about
wouldn't have that data point on me I
know so I mean it's I think it's a
fascinating study because there's so
much interesting data it's a big data
study right even you can look on
Facebook you can see who is linked to
whom and then you can look at shared
friends within their circle that data is
available and you can compare it and and
see if you can figure something out now
I wonder you know how long did they wait
to see if these people broke up it's one
thing to say
people with more mutual friends will
break up well in what
length of time all right if you wait
longer will everybody break up someone's
gonna die right that's I think a likely
outcome - but there is something also to
be said I think about this hypothesis
that if you have your own life
you're going to have a stronger
relationship with your partner because
you're not constantly going to be around
one another and you're gonna have a
sense of Independence in a sense of
personal identity which i think is very
healthy right and then you go home and
untie them as you said yeah after
they're my wife and I are inherently
antisocial I go out to do things purely
for professional reasons really and I
try to be charming and I try to look
like I'm enjoying other people's company
but I've done a perfectly manageable job
but I'm really the truth is I'm way too
much of a narcissist to care you know
later on today I'll be saying I was on
some show with a guy in a real very être
I don't know as I as I go out into the
world and oh my point is that despite
the fact that my wife and I have no
friends
we do have high dispersion there's some
point there I always know what I'm
talking about when I start yeah you got
no friends and none of those nobodies
that's my point
thank God none of the people that I
don't know know the people that my wife
doesn't know brilliant right so how then
watch how I do this will the marketers
use this on Facebook because doesn't
this all this is exactly why Sir Arthur
has told me I'm not allowed to breed
with my dog that way you definitely
can't do that I think maybe in Kentucky
we're gonna target these individuals and
say get out make new friends it's less
likely that you'll break up with your
boyfriend if you do so Oh or that they
let's go the other way and say the
people that are more likely to break up
they're going to have the singles
websites are going to be advertising on
there right there will be a targeting of
the Ashley Madison yeah tell the people
what actually Madison Madison is dad
you're the one married person here
it keeps sending me emails that say
don't waste your time have an affair
don't be sad have an affair which is
just not helping at all with anything
I've struggled with in my life you see
the billboards all over LA it's so yeah
so final thought on this how much of all
this digital stuff is is really
affecting our actual relationships like
when is it gonna be like are you gonna
have to Skype with someone before you
know now you go on an app and meet
somebody but is it gonna be you're gonna
have to video Skype with them first and
then you're gonna have to text them like
I'm really doing something there's
something Orwellian yeah about the idea
that we call it social networking when
what we're doing is sitting alone at
home at a computer I think there's it's
genuinely mind-bending to think that
that's considered a social life but your
definition of a loan is that there's
nobody else in the room with you
physically and I think for a lot of
young people that's not their definition
of alone anymore and I think that
there's a whole subset of the population
who previously had a very difficult time
connecting with individuals you even
made that point earlier about atheists
for example growing up in the Bible Belt
not knowing anybody in their
neighborhood who has you know similar
views you get online and now you can
connect with people so I think that you
know there there are positive outcomes
there are negative outcomes but to say
how much of our our new kind of digital
world is affecting our relationships
it's impossible to know I would say it
in the same breath it's both impossible
to know and it's completely affecting us
yeah there's no way that it couldn't I
don't know if it's positive negative or
net neutral but the way that we interact
is is completely changed because we're
all connected online yeah there has
definitely been a through line to this
whole episode of the show I think
rationality and something all right
let's move on we got one more story
we're probably going to all be destroyed
by an asteroid you probably knew that
already they have been entering our
atmosphere for a long long time
you may even remember this one from
Russia last year
all right that's just one example and
this has been happening all over the
place Russian talk radio sounds really
terrible by the way but we're just a
matter of time away from this
all right so that's from the movie deep
impact remember that came out like the
same week that Armageddon came out they
had to asteroid movies that's the much
better one in my humble opinion but
don't worry about asteroids people
because the UN is on it because they're
so good at everything aren't they the
special political and decolonization
committee is welcoming the idea of
setting up a series of groups to act as
a warning system they're going to deal
with issues related to decolonization
Human Rights peacekeeping outer space
atomic radiation and more the UN
literally can't do anything on earth but
apparently we're gonna be able to do
things off planet and they also have an
office for outer space affairs and let's
let's look at the International
mechanism which they've set up to deal
with asteroids the international
asteroid warning network comprises of a
wide spectrum of organizations for
discovering monitoring and
characterizing potential hazardous
near-earth objects it will recommend
criteria for notification of an
emergency impact threat and to study and
plan response activities take it away to
here's the space mission planning
advisory group statement the main
objective of this group to be
established would be to lay out the
framework timeline and options for
initiating and executing space mission
response activities report the UN does
not do much of anything some good stuff
with feeding people but there's so much
that's good they do some good stuff but
so much of what they do is just
bureaucratic nonsense we still have
people being slaughtered in Syria and
nothing's really changing so is there
any chance that this group of people in
suits and ties and bureaucrats and
technocrats can sit down and figure out
a problem as big as when an asteroid is
going to destroy earth well I think the
truth the truth is that there are space
agencies across the world and those
space agencies are not unified and the
hope would be that if there were an
impending threat that one of the space
agencies I don't think that the UN that
this organization is probably going to
be the go-to for monitoring of
near-earth impacts right they're not
gonna be monitoring asteroids or meteors
very closely I know that there was some
talk about raising enough money to put
out a telescope specifically for that
but I think that there are organizations
that are better equipped to do that so
long as we don't continue to defund them
right the problem is those organization
you know NASA is an American
organization you have the Russian space
Space Agency we've shown that
partnerships work very well we no longer
have shuttles so we now ride the Soyuz
capsule to get up to the International
Space Station right so people don't
really realize this the Russians
actually now have to take us right to
the International Space Station we used
to go we don't do that until until kind
of a private space company perhaps
SpaceX or Virgin Galactic can put
together a rocket that's not just
delivering payload that can actually
deliver humans we're relying on the
Russians now in order to get up to the
ISS so I think the issue here is that we
are a globe we have a global society if
an asteroid is going to impact earth
ultimately and that is a legitimate
possibility we have to have a plan in
place and relying on in any one
individual nation to play big brother
may not be the best way to do it so
whether it's the UN or another global
organization don't get me wrong we have
we don't have a good track record of
playing nice with other countries but I
think that it is important for us to be
able to maybe it sounds like
hippie-dippie [ __ ] but to be able to
band together and work together to
prevent catastrophe right and that's my
point the UN doesn't really work well
together to prevent things that are
happening on earth so is there any
chance we could come together and well
build some sort of super question those
the right question is there not a better
option pick a question give me a hand
there's a couple of subtextual things
that are at work here first of all
recently the Japanese space
administration and I don't remember what
they're called we did some math on a
meteor that the US had said was not
going to impact earth in 2032 and said
we think it's a lot more likely than you
do and that started to create the the
sense that there is a need for greater
communication between international
space agencies but moreover this I think
we as a species have been widely and
largely distracted by fantasies of
apocalypse since the beginning of
organized government governance the
sense that things are going to end soon
keeps people distracted from solving
large societal problems and these
societal problems are caused by economic
influences far more than by any force of
nature and you know economic influences
are purely abstract and money doesn't
really exist it's just a sort of an
agreed-upon abstraction of value I just
watch that guy's the movie so I'm on
board that I'm glad to hear that someone
watch that so we're dealing with the the
apocalyptic fantasy of modern America
isn't that five seven horsemen five
horsemen and three horsemen however
that's not gonna happen and the the
zombie guy isn't gonna cut you know that
we have a scientific apocalypse fantasy
and that all sort of frees us of
responsibility for things like you know
we're making the Pacific Ocean
radioactive I don't worry about it a
meteorite is gonna come in 2032 you know
we've got people starving all over the
wealthiest nation in history don't worry
about it we're all gonna die in a couple
of years we can't really solve all those
problems in that much time and my
feeling is what we should do and again
it may sound hippy dippy is set about
joining together to solve human problems
where we can as we can for the good of
humanity and then if there is a sudden
horrific death to everything that we
know that could just come as a happy
surprise right then we did we did the
best we could I think those are some
really really good points I think the
one thing that I would add to that is
that it doesn't have to be an either/or
scenario yes but within a certain
organization perhaps it does maybe the
UN obviously doesn't have the
organizational skills or the manpower to
even address some of the humanitarian
crises that they
we're first banded together to be able
to address so maybe this is better left
not in the hands of the UN but of some
sort of coalition of the existing space
agencies right the UN can serve perhaps
as a bridging mechanism between even
need to there may be some sort of treaty
established amongst the different space
agencies we already see that
fundamentally the scientists who work
there are interested in you know
preventing catastrophe and in in
bettering the lives of everybody on the
globe through space exploration they all
have a common goal there which is to
learn as much about the cosmos as we can
in order to help us more here on earth
and and you already see so many kind of
international coalition's that are
forming to try and get people to Mars to
try and get people back to the moon try
and get people as we were just saying to
the ISS why couldn't there be some sort
of asteroid watch coalition that was
that was presented between all of those
different organisms yeah
so is part of the problem here also that
we go as sort of as you're saying we go
from human crisis to human crisis
remember when everyone thought y2k was
gonna end the world right then two years
ago or was it last year what year was I
guess 2012 we thought the Mayan thing
was gonna kill me nobody legitimately
thought that was what a guy nobody you
like read a book really no well I
thought one person did but really when
these types of things come up and then
nothing happens and everyone always
thinks every other year you know the
Antichrist is coming a little thing that
when we actually have something that
legitimately could do it like an
asteroid we can't really band together
because we've had these sort of cry
Wolfe well so I think with things like
asteroids we are crying wolf I mean you
see the same thing you know there's a
difference between legitimate threats
and illegitimate threats you know is a
satan gonna come to earth no want to be
riding an asteroid isn't that what they
would say is there gonna be a zombie
apocalypse no but when people get scared
about swine flu or bird flu it's it's
it's more approaching a legitimate fear
of course though there's so much fear
mongering in the media that even swine
flu and bird flu weren't legitimate
fears for some sort of like cataclysmic
event right and so I think what it's
really about is understanding the data
understanding scale and and being able
to to know the difference between a
legitimate risk
and a risk that has been blown out of
proportion by that's exactly bringing us
home again humans love drama we live for
drama we remember the exciting moments
and we seek out the exciting moments and
at this point our we have the most
powerful technology for information and
education that has ever been available
to us and instead all we are using it
for is titillation of the drama impulse
so you know news stations the the
purported mainstream news and I'm using
the term so loosely are in the business
of selling xanax because that's their
sponsor and the human mind is hardwired
so that if you're in the forest foraging
for food and there's a fuzzy rabbit you
might be able to eat you look at the
rabbit because it's moving but then if
there's a bear that might kill you your
focus is on the bear yeah it's got to be
on the bear until the bear is gone and
all the news does now is say look at the
bear buys an axe look at the bear buys
an axe that's all it does all right well
don't look at the bear people we're
trying to give you some natural xanex
right here I want to thank Cara Santa
Maria Dylan Brody subscribe it's right
down there that's all you got to do this
was the EDIUS show we have ever done all
right thanks guys we'll do it again
hey guys the Rubin reports brought to
you by Cooper comm they have up to 75%
off pet treats choose toys and more and
if you use code RR you get another 20%
that's a lot of percentage right there I
can't do that kind of math the link is
right down below
Cooper comm code RR